so your co-star from White Lotus Cindy
Sweeney she was here and she was Fanning
over you just saying how incredible that
you were and you've become like one of
her biggest fans right well she is I
just find her so impressive you know we
we met for the first time when we were
doing White Lotus she was playing my
daughter I can't believe it that now I
have like a series of like these
incredible young women who have been my
daughters I feel like I know I have all
this all these TV daughters but Sydney
there's something about her she's so
incredibly talented and so incredible
becoming so incredibly successful I mean
she's just really like honed into who
she is and I really admire that at such
a young age to be able to tap into that
but also stay really grounded she's
super close with her family she you know
it's hard to do in this industry it
really is and I you know so yeah I
really fire her I love this about this
story that I think my favorite part is
just the supporting of other women like
how important do you think that is
because I feel like we always get pitted
against each other and it's not fair to
other women and to society in general
but also to us because it's like no
one's thinking that way well you know
it's funny that you I mean that to me
has been one of the most important parts
of my career really just really of my
life because no matter what I if if I
was you know a teacher in a public
school I would still be wanting to do
the exact same thing and that is to
support my fellow humans but
particularly my fellow women and like
lift each other up and you know it's
funny talking about the Emmys the other
night because in my category it there
were uh five of us from my show the
White Lotus that were nominated in my
category yeah and I mean congratulations
being a part of such a killer cast
that's what I'm saying that's still
amazing cast but that's you that's an
honor that you're with all these people
that are that's cool it was so cool I've
never had experience like that and
everybody was like oh are you oh you
know are you feeling competitive and you
know and I thought oh my gosh I could
not feel more thrilled that I get to be
there with my fellow actresses like look
at look at you being lifted up like my
fellow actresses in the category
and we can like do that for each other
and acknowledge each other and by the
way I'm inspired by each and every one
of them so it's just to me like boy if
we if we can hold each other and support
each other in a world that wants to tear
us down yeah that's that's the goal
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]